you know we like kids to know that all
dreams are possible if you believe in
yourself
january 26th is a hard day for the
bryant family
this time last year kobe bryant and his
13 year old daughter gianna were killed
in a helicopter crash
and on tuesday kobe's wife and gigi's
mom
vanessa bryant paid tribute to them by
sharing a touching letter written by one
of the late
teen's friends in the note posted on
instagram
gigi's friend aubry wrote that she's
thinking and praying for vanessa
constantly and cannot begin to
comprehend what she's going through
gianna's smile and attitude pushed me to
be better
you have probably heard this but if i
ever become a mom
i hope my daughter turns out exactly as
yours did
aubry remembered her friend as someone
who was kind caring and endlessly polite
who taught her and her other friends to
be better versions of themselves
and while aubrey noted that she's had a
pit of despair thinking about gianna and
what she could have accomplished had she
had a couple more years
she's tried to refocus her thoughts on
the marks she did leave on this earth
i can say that she changed our lives her
simple actions made all of us
a better person and i believe that the
results of this will never stop
appearing
and if all that wasn't sweet enough
gigi's friend concluded her letter with
a compliment to vanessa for raising
such a standout young woman writing you
did it right mrs bryant
and we are all eternally grateful to you
vanessa shared the letter alongside a
lengthy caption that read in part
quote i miss my baby girl and kobe kobe
so much adding i will never understand
why how this tragedy could have happened
to such
beautiful kind and amazing human beings
it still doesn't seem real
kobe we did it right she's amazing
you were there i was there i was there
taking pictures helping
you know doing everything i possibly can
to make the process easier for my wife
and you know but ultimately
you know she did all the work i was just
there just trying to help out
and vanessa she couldn't be more
grateful for all the love and support
a source tells et that the 38 year old
and the three other daughters she shared
with kobe
18 year old natalia four-year-old bianca
and one-year-old capri
have been extremely thankful for their
friends and family who have helped them
cope with the tragedy
our responsibility is to always inspire
and try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned
and share those with the next generation
so that they can start
their journey with a lego the source
adds that vanessa plans to continue to
honor kobe and gianna's legacy and has
some projects in the works to do
just that one of those projects is
taking control over kobe's production
studio
according to the la times vanessa is now
the president
and ceo of granity studios which was
founded in 2013
and is best known for producing kobe's
animated short
deer basketball which won the nba star
in
oscar in 2018. my heart can take the
pounding
my mind can handle the grind but my body
knows it's time to say goodbye
and that's okay i'm ready to let you go
[Music]